Samuel leads here and congratulations on
booking onto the crash course we never
have a fantastic time so come with very
high expectations most people that come
on the crash course they are wanting to
learn how to find deals and be a
property investor well that's exactly
what you're going to learn but if you'd
like to have access to my deals that I'm
finding as well then you need to become
a cherry-pick member what is a
cherry-pick member well it means the
best of the best deals that I find and
pick the forever reason I can't by
myself there may be lease option
agreements rent to rent below market
value opportunities really good HMO
properties if I can't buy the myself I
send them out to my cherry-pick members
and I'll give them the opportunity to be
able to buy the property instead you'll
also be included into our secret
Facebook group where you'll be kept up
to date on goldmine areas and news and
tips and also give them first refusal on
properties giving discounts off
introducing fees there's a ton of value
in being a cherry-pick matter but what
I'd say is don't take my word for it
just give it a try there's no contract
and see how you get up and I look
forward to working with you very very
soon